really also but you don't want you want
divorce to be made illegal yes why yes
because I don't think what we have today
is really marriage What is marriage it's
For Better or For Worse for richer for
poorer and sickness and in health till
death do us part that's what marriage is
supposed to be but feminists have ruined
marriage for the people that actually
believe in marriage when there is a 50
divorce rate and the average
I I didn't say that it was all down to
the women
you asked why I want divorce to be
banned can I finish yeah first so I'm
saying you know the people that believe
in divorce go be in long-term
relationships leave marriage for the
people that actually believe in For
Better or For Worse for richer for poor
in sickness and in health till death do
us part